今天來做個手沖
我在IG上問了大家對於手沖相關的問題
反正我每次沒有梗呢
我就會在IG上面搞這一套
反正我跟你講啦
下禮拜我應該也是沒梗啦
所以下禮拜就是照樣照劇嘛
你對濃縮有什麼疑惑
那今天這個禮拜呢
我們就先講手沖的好不好
然後自我介紹一下
喔!喔!
欸!
嘿!嘿!我是威力!
威力是幹嘛的?
我是出貨小幫手!
喔!OK!
威力,我們的新程也不行了喔!
來一陣子!
對!三個月了!
很優秀喔!
等一下看看,口條不好就...
試用期就結束了!
不會啦!不會!
優秀!好不好!
那待會威力就...
念問題,然後我來回答
好不好,這樣我就省在那邊看來看去
定題
Mili Lee的
他說想知道比較不會出錯
最常用的Recipe
好,這個看個人口味哦
像我們喜歡濃一點的
我們做1-10
那有的是1-12
有的1-14也有
16也有
就是說你喜歡味道比較展開呢
可以做1比14
我覺得還不錯
像我喜歡喝起來就是紮實的那種感覺
所以我會用1比10
當然你如果是深焙的
你可以比例要大一點
比如說我們現在以中焙為準
假設是12
深焙你可以用到14
因為深焙它萃取它的容出率比較高
幾個數字給你參考
10、12、10、16
那你焙度越深可以放越大
焙度越淺放越低
然後你還是按照自己的口味
所以沒有一個標準答案
這個回答後面的問題之前
前提
是說
這個咖啡沖出來怎麼樣
怎麼樣會怎麼樣
這有點哲學問題
因為你同一份粉
你沒有辦法再沖第二次
是不是
所以
但有些經驗可以參考
我的經驗
我的不一定就是很標準的
我的經驗而已
第二題
一樣是Midl的
那就不回了
下一題
第三題
Q-SHIP菜的問題
他說請問手沖單點注水
繞小圈注水
繞大圈注水
在風味上會有什麼顯著的差異嗎
當然小圈比較集中嘛
你知道小圈它在中間萃取對不對
它容易形成一個類似通道
在中間
那你變成你旁邊就
比較萃取不到
很有可能頭重腳輕喔
喝下去味道好雜啊但是水水的
那你如果大圈的話呢
它平均萃取了對不對
它就會顯得風味好像又比較薄弱
平均但是比較薄弱
所以最好的方式呢還是
就是漸漸的把它擴大
像我們一般點滴法也是會這樣子
這樣子點的
它不會是同一個點,拼命點的
OK?
聞到木質掉的時候
還要繼續萃取嗎?
豆子本身它是木質的
你如果聞到軟木骰那種感覺
那其實已經尾聲了
很尾聲了
很厚面了
就不要再萃取了
下一題是什麼?
下一題是NP39271
如何沖出穩定味道的手沖咖啡?
穩定喔?
難耶!
雙胞胎也長不一樣
沒有完全一樣
所以
我覺得
不要太緊張
應該是要放鬆你
放鬆心情你就去試嘛
味道很好那很開心
那沖著過程稍微記一下
比如說什麼比例啊
水分大概多少
就可以了
會很類似
如果完全一模一樣
如果那麼強迫的話
那你會喝咖啡會覺得很痛苦啊
對不對
你永遠在追求上一杯
那你現在當下這一杯怎麼辦
下一題
Kaley1229
如何知道自己是否進步
哎呀
拿給最討厭你的喝
然後他明天還跟你要的話
代表你已經進步了
你不能拿給你最喜歡的人啦
你衝得很爛
欸好棒安慰你拿給GY一點也不要拿給我啦因為我一定會說很好太棒了你是用我家的豆子嗎下一題
想請教冰手沖
冰手沖我們去年有做五種夏天的冰咖啡
你麻煩去考古一下
下一題
想請問老闆為什麼很偶爾沖煮完咖啡
馬上聞咖啡一時
會聞到類似蟑螂的味道
蟑螂
好好檢查一下
搞不好真的有蟑螂耶
摩托機裡面
摩托機裡面有蟑螂
有可能
蟑螂味嗎?應該是一種油耗味
一般如果我們培肚稍微深一點的豆子
它會出油對不對
出油呢
它會冒出來對不對
你看到豆子油油的
然後過一陣子呢
你會看到油不見了
那油去哪裡呢?
揮發了嗎?不是
因為咖啡豆是很會吸水分的
它會把油再吸回來
吸回來就在裡面
變成油耗味
所以那應該是油耗味
如果你很確定是蟑螂味
那你豆子要檢查一下
然後摩托機檢查一下
好不好
下一題
D R A N 提問的
他說想請問小霸王
前段和後段段水所形成的風味差異
好!這個呢
三、四年前我就拍過了
叫星期五手沖熱時代
有沒有
拿湯匙接
你第一次注水接
第二次注水再接
然後馬上喝
你會發現有一段特別平均
然後呢
後面就是比較淡
前面我很集中喔
但是你沖出來的就是
比如說這幾隻注水的綜合
你常常用湯匙的話
其實你會進步很快
因為我是這樣做的
下一題
注水的手法
對於風味表現
真的會有很大的影響嗎?
大原則不要反
其實我覺得沒有什麼大影響
比如說你總萃取時間
不要過長也不要過短
研磨度正確
基本上我覺得不會有太大問題
一定要
8字S型什麼的不用不用不用
你就覺得它快乾了加點水
也可以
分三次分四次五次都可以
下一題
等我一下
剛因為我沒有念名字
我現在補一個要買
好啦
那你們覺得它試用期會過
哈哈哈
會啦會啦會過了
該那題是
Jespresso問的
好
下一題
水質那個賴魚方
提問的水質
我自己是用巴克濾心過濾的
好的
萃取率
跟你這個水裡面含的礦物質量
雜質量有關係
你如果水太過於乾淨
它其實沒有辦法把咖啡裡面的物質吸附
然後帶下來
所以它其實要水
也不能完全軟水
它會做出來的東西沒有什麼味道
那你如果用礦泉水
有些牌子的
礦泉水過多的
它味道會太雜
也不是太好
所以你用8顆濾鏡
那可能水很軟喔
水很軟的話
它帶不出太多縫揮
你可以試試看
用比較一般的水來試試看
欸這個沒有
好沒關係
你有強迫症
打廣告
好
下一題
J-Cup
提問的
說沖到後面
粉塵在下面
水有點緩慢下沉
該停止萃取了嗎
有些豆子它的結構會讓細粉量比較多
細粉量過多呢,它就會沉到下面
好像水流會變慢,塞住的感覺
要嘛就換個濾杯
要嘛就是加大你的水柱
你還是要達到你原本希望的水分比
我們前面有回答到
OK,下一題
Milk Tea的提問
它說怎麼沖教義沖出甜味
同一個道指別人說很甜
我沖的只有3
好!個性問題
不是啦
我覺得水溫影響蠻大的
假設都以中培度來講
你水溫稍微降一點
它甜感比較容易出現
然後手法稍微放慢一些
所以你可以試試看調整你的水溫
如果水溫調整不明顯
那可能換個摩托機假如是用同一個摩托機那換個淹沒度也會有影響那稍微偏細會稍微甜一點但是如果太細就會苦下一題下一題由Mosh Huang
他說
常喝不出豆子
介紹上寫的風味
這個Mosh喔
應該跟我認識20年了
難道不知道我也喝不出來嗎
呵呵呵呵
這我們之前有講過
同一部電影
你看跟影評人看就是不一樣
對不對
影評人都可以看到哇
奶奶的細節
你就是看不到
對不對
所以你跟貝特斯的感受不一樣
是很正常的
不要擔心
下一題由JCOP413提的問題
他說手沖時水不小心沖到濾杯壁
這時會造成無效萃取還是過度萃取
你如果碰到壁沒有關係不要緊張
你已經碰到一個邊了嘛
那就是繞一整圈就好了
然後再往中間注水長一點時間就可以了
好 下一題
下一題由 DTCF5的提問
沒有溫控壺溫度不好掌握
那要買一個 下一題
BYN977 提問的
他說怎麼沖出茉莉花茶的味道
這要看豆子本身有沒有
好下一題
通常非洲的比較有機會
金煙樹
這麼嚴肅啊
好 OK
怎麼決定每隻豆子的沖煮方式
分幾次注水
一次注水量多少
不要糾結
你找出一套你習慣的
比如說好
那我們就以後你就悶蒸完
只能加三次
然後要搞到你的水分比
好不好
那你當然是比如說
第一次注水跟第二次注水的間隔
可能是越來越緊湊嘛
前面第一次跟第二次隔長一點
第二次第三次隔短一點
好不好
原則是這樣
然後你會找到你自己的Tempo
沒有人規定一定要怎樣
我是這樣
給你參考
下一個
BYBRABRABRA的提問
老師煮到苦苦的味道
那就是可能磨豆機不夠厲害
磨豆機細粉過多
或者是水溫過高
或者是你的動作太慢
我看到很多人
光悶蒸第一次煮水就搞了30秒
也就是太慢了
所以你悶蒸的時候動作要快
然後磨豆機檢查一下
很有可能喔!細粉過多酷酷的
下一題
由830082的提問
他說豆子粗細調整跟如何不過度萃取
不過度萃取喔?
過不過度要看個人耶
有些人就喜歡過度的耶
這個我就...
但粗細度我可以大概跟大家提一下
比如說這K-MAX它有16個
你如果是做手沖的話
你可以用9、8、7
就是它中間的16除以28
減1加1去調整
如果你覺得8太苦了
那就調成9
如果你覺得8太清淡了
那就調成7
因為每個摩托機它的設定都不一樣
那你如果做手沖
最簡單的方法就是中間只加一格
通常都會還可以
QWER提問了
為什麼虎記的豆子隨便沖都這麼好喝?
假的
下一題
TSZHO
怎樣才能沖到好像老闆一樣那麼的瀟灑?
我瀟灑嗎?
瀟灑就對了
哎呀我跟你說
這個有可能衝得多嗎?
比較隨便一點
就是動作帥
喝采可能還好
我覺得我們吧台手他們都做得多好
下一題
UNI-BRABRABRA的提問
然後他說
咖啡有時候喝起來有點澀澀的味道
怎麼會澀澀的呢?
不會澀澀的啦
我跟你講那不是你的問題
會澀澀的呢?
可能是烘豆式的問題
就在烘焙的過程呢
豆子裡面的水分沒有排掉
那它憋在裡面呢
就會澀澀的
好不好
下一題
Mr.Bean 的提問
沖煮過程中如何觀察粉狀態
然後再及時修正手法其實我覺得很簡單你假設已經撞斃,你就全部裝閉假設你已經凹陷了那你可以直接大水
把邊緣沖散
然後下去
終歸一句是要放輕鬆一點
其實方法我覺得沒有那麼困難
好下一個
ARCHER的提問
如何更加穩定的沖出
好喝富含喜歡的味道
香氣的咖啡
混沌定律你知道吧
所有事情都在變動當中
微小的變動
比如說夏天一定要37度嘛
不一定
對嘛
那是不是它也會走到冬天呢
這些事實上就是很混沌的
但是大方向是緩緩的
會讓你到達的
好不好
所以不要去追求說
今天跟昨天一樣
昨天跟上一次一樣
別別別
當下這個比較重要
你其實心情放輕鬆
沖出來都會蠻好喝的啦
我覺得
OK 下一個
WWCH的提問
水的溫度控制
深焙低一點
淺焙高一點
那多高多低對不對
就是你可以90度
有這三個檔位
給你切對不對
你當你有溫控壺最好
然後呢
水的溫度扣置
其實這也是一個很奧妙的問題
冬天洗澡洗幾度
夏天洗澡洗幾度
是不是
所以你要對
現在你周邊的環境也要有一點感受
好不好
所以隨時要微調整的
它不是說
啊你水就是一定多少
你要看你豆子只有多少
對吧
所以你真的要講到很細的話
你永遠歸類不完
所以呢
放鬆心情就好
下一題
LOVEWE 0401 愚人節出生的
我是手沖新手
目前沒有購入溫度計與電子晶
但發現手沖喝出來
明顯感覺苦澀感要如何改善
造成苦澀感的原因
可能是萃取過頭
然後磨豆機的細粉過多
其實齁,你說溫度計啊很重要嗎?
因為我們在入行的時候
不流行這個
電子秤嗎?有很少人用
不會變成標配
以前就是選配
現在好像沒有這兩樣
你就覺得不會秤了
其實沒有啊,沒這件事情
你要相信你的感覺
你的感覺就是最厲害的
好啦,今天這個問題就回答到這邊
其實我看裡面這些問題啊
主要第一個是
會很糾結在手法上面
手法呢
哎呀!到底要點滴呀
要什麼
一刀流呀
什麼分段呀
比如說你喜歡層次多一點
那你可以用分段
像我們
我們用分段的
那你喜歡味道接的很平順的
那你可以一刀流嘛
你可以最近沖咖啡的時候
你就試試看
我今天用一刀流
我明天用這個分段
然後看哪一個是你最喜歡的
說出來味道是你最喜歡的
那你回去用那個就好啦
心血來潮可以隨時改一下嘛
無所謂的
所以其實我覺得這個
喝咖啡很日常啊
你不要把它當成一個好像玄學
一定要如何如何做
沒有人規定
也沒有教科書
再來是
最多是對自己沒信心嘛
比如說我們看到好多人在問說
為什麼我喝不出那味道
喝不出這味道
你本來每個人感受就不一樣
再來是
太緊張了
我覺得咖啡這件事情是一個很放鬆的事情
你隨便沖也可以
你要很認真享受那個意識感、野心
都OK
磨豆雞買好一點嗎?
欸!懂銷售哦!
PINU 做義式
可以!
小富士 鬼刀做手沖好喝
那喜歡味道比較忠實的
你可以選頻道
我覺得磨豆機滿重要的
其實手沖是很有趣的
反正現在應該家戶戶都自己會沖的嘛
而且我相信很多人不用看我們Q&A
就已經沖得很厲害了
尤其是我們虎記的客人
選對豆子就對了
好不好
好!今天問題就回到這邊
下個禮拜我們來回答濃縮相關的問題
哦!對!我跟你講
威力其實除了出貨小幫手以外
我們公司的器材類相關
有拆解、回修、水用上的問題
都是威力負責的
好不好?可以嗎?可以!
拜拜!